[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
i am so pleased to be joined right now
by the president of the young americas
foundation
you might remember him as the governor
of wisconsin
that would be governor scott walker
governor walker thank you for being here
oh michael it's a pleasure to be with
you
governor i cannot tell you how excited i
am one that you're
now running young america's foundation
very exciting i love doing events with
yaff been doing it for
years now it's one of my favorite things
we do but i'm even more excited
about this little document here this
action plan
called the long game i want to get into
what the long game means i'm just
excited to
see those words because i feel that too
often
conservatives have the short game and
they focus all of their attention on the
short game
and what happens we lose the culture and
we lose the politics and we lose
all of our sort of cherished
institutions in the long run because the
left has a much
much longer political vision so tell me
about how we're going to win
in the long game well we are i'm a huge
optimist i i came of age under ronald
reagan so it's
appropriately associated with yf
considering uh they're
uh owning and operating the reagan ranch
amongst other things but it's it's
part of the reason why i'm a
conservative and more importantly an
optimist
but for us it really is about the long
game we looked at this and we said
america is under siege we see it for
years we've warned about in our college
campuses
but increasingly we see it in our
culture we see in our communications
with the censorship from big tech
and as you just alluded to the left is
really
been at this for quite some time they've
literally been working on this for
decades
right back to the 1960s so it's not
going to be just a news cycle or even a
presidential cycle
it does take the long game with a series
of things i'll give you a good example
we think we can have right now we're the
largest conservative
student organization in the country we
uh support
students on about 2 000 campuses across
the nation
but there's four thousand uh there's 4
000 public and private colleges and
universities in this country we've got
to be in all of them yes on the long
game we're going to be on all them we're
going to have a presence there
we're going to support students there we
know that we've got to do that even if
it doesn't happen tomorrow
over the next few years as part of our
long game plan that's exactly
just one of the many things we've got
outlined could i volunteer to go speak
at the university of hawaii is that i
don't know
i don't know if someone signed up for
that about february 6th on reagan's
birthday that would be great yeah i
think that would be terrific well and if
it's another one of our points is to
have speakers
in all 50 states representing campuses
big and small like so hawaii would be
one of those right
this is great maybe alaska in the summer
you got it all covered yeah that's
really quite beautiful
nice you know obviously yaf has been
around for
quite a bit of time founded in bill
buckley's living room right
in sharon connecticut uh
you know the more things change the more
they stay the same and as conservatives
it's not
we don't just want to go back to some
random date in the past but we want to
preserve and conserve
all the great stuff from our
civilization and bring it forward
into the future what is it
about this moment that we're in that is
uh
you know what is the same that buckley
saw how is it different how are the
challenges unique and then how are we
going to meet them
yeah when when william buckley brought
together that group about a hundred
students
it was right 1960 it was coming right at
the end of
at that time probably the most heavily
contested presidential election the most
divisive time
from a presidential election in american
history back then and we were you know
going into the coming off
korean war going in the vietnam war
really dicey times
in terms of american culture
particularly on our college campuses
so that's consistent we've seen it all
throughout our time in college we've
seen it over the years
but i think what makes it different i
had plenty of left-wing professors but
today
it's not just the left-wing professors
that are a problem for our students it's
the activists
it's the rebel rousers it's the folks
that come in and not only do they want
to challenge you they want to just wipe
you out
and in many ways this is something i'm
accustomed to i remember a decade ago i
can certainly relate
we i like to point out that the the
occupy movement did not start on wall
street
it started on my street madison
wisconsin that's right one of the best
examples of the irony of the left
uh the absolute absurdity was i remember
around our state capitol in the midst of
literally about a hundred thousand
protesters occupying our capital
was a back of a car with a bumper
sticker one side
that said coexist you know those typical
ones with the religious symbols
coexist and right next to it was one
that said recall scott walker
you just can't make this stuff up but
that's exactly what's happening today
it's on our campuses and in our culture
uh people are saying it's not enough to
win the debate
they want to annihilate us in my case
they want to recall me they want to
cancel us
they don't want conservatives to have
any voice in society
and that's why we've got to push back
this i think actually brings up
something that is very
difficult to understand but very
important to the conservative movement
which is
for people who know you and for people
who don't know you by the way
you're a very nice guy you're a very
amiable affable guy
that you almost forget that you faced
you know one of the most intense
political challenges of anybody in this
country over the past
couple of decades you survived that
now i you know i'm excited that you'll
be bringing that spine to
to yaf but how do we balance that out
because you know part of me thinks i
wish we could just
get along and maybe not sing kumbaya but
at least be able to go to a cocktail
party with
people on on the left and make jokes
about one another make jokes about
ourselves
but then part of me thinks that the left
is so
vicious right now and they're destroying
people canceling people
there there really seem to be out for
blood
how are we supposed to position
ourselves to fight back
well it's the beauty at this time for yf
and if folks want to learn more they can
go to yaf.org
long game to see the kind of things
we're talking about but i think it's a
combination of being strong
it's why going back to ideas not just
being focused on any one personality
but going back to ideas and making the
case for
ideas and how they change people's lives
much of the last four years was a litmus
test particularly in the media whether
you were for the president or against
the president
and there was no space in between on any
of those issues
of course they were obviously very
biased against president trump
throughout that time
but i think right now it's built for a
time for organizations such as young
america's foundation
because we're focused on ideas ron
robinson you know not just going back to
william
buckley but ron robinson who was
president for more than four decades
he jokes he's not a big guy for term
limits at least in this case
but he did a fabulous job of creating an
organization that that really offers
quality
information including people like you
speaking on campus and
plenty of other your colleagues at the
daily wire so it's
but but the kicker there is to take
those big bold ideas
and then be aggressive in not changing
what we do
but changing how many more people we
reach and that's where we have to be
strong that's where we have to fight
back
because the battle is not over winning
and losing over ideas we win
on ideas if we have a level or close to
level playing field right
where we got to be strong and what we do
have to be willing to fight back is to
say under no circumstances
when we accept anyone violating our
right to speak out freely whether it's
on a campus
whether it's in our culture in general
and particularly these days when it's
speaking out on
on platforms like twitter or facebook or
other things on social media but
so i i totally agree if we're going to
win
we're going to win on ideas and then
translating those ideas into action
something yes been doing for a long time
and and i i suspect we'll
do even more so into the future
that's why you focus on education that's
why you focus on these lectures that's
why you focus on college campuses
but my fear is is it too late
when you get to college that oh you're
exactly right about that so the long
game another key component is starting
earlier
i think about i was 12 years old when
ronald reagan ran for president united
states
other than my parents i don't think any
other adult had a greater impact
on me and many of my generation not just
as conservatives or even as republicans
but as optimists
he had this eternal belief in the
american people he was a happy warrior
he was
strong and bold but he had this you know
this shining city on the hill type
mindset
and i think that was very attractive not
only to those of us who were
conservatives but even some of the
so-called
reagan democrats back in the day so i
think it's
it's important uh to do that but i i
also think one of the big mistakes that
we make
is we think and talk with our head the
left thinks and talks with their heart
we need to think with our head but talk
with our heart and that's as you get to
younger ages
you've got to again not concede the
logic but going into high school
and a part of our plan is to go
aggressively into preteens
in the middle school junior high and
even start working only with the
students in elementary school
but but with their parents as well to
give them the materials and the tools to
teach them
why america is exceptional why this is a
great country
because the left is trying to tell them
how awful we are
and that couldn't be farther from the
truth no this is something that
that the left has done very very well
and i've detailed it in in my book
speechless which you very kindly
have blurbed and i i always
thought especially as a college
conservative well look if we just win in
debate club
if we just win then then people will
change their minds
but when you're young when you're more
impressionable
you're really shaping your mind you're
shaping your worldview
that is why the left goes in to high
schools
middle schools even elementary schools
now and they are
telling a certain story i mean they're
telling a vision of america that is the
1619
project vision of america it's a very
different one
than than we have why have they been so
successful at that
why have they beaten us on this well for
precisely what you talked about we
played by the old rules
yes and not that we shouldn't play by
rules because we're not you know we're
not going to
stoop to some of the tactics they do but
we've got to play by our own set of
rules going forward and i'll give you
two examples that tie a conference
the conference that you were part of so
we had our first in-person event about a
month ago in february
down in miami you course from senator
cruz were down there doing part of the
verdict on site
but part of the reason why we went and
had that conference there was one
because florida is open
thank you ron desantis who i think is
arguably the best uh governor in the
country just standing up and i
appreciate being a good governor
uh what what an impact you know a thing
or two about i hope
but i think he's done a fabulous job so
we picked florida because open but we
picked miami
because of the story we wanted to tell
when you're that close to cuba
we had only speakers talk about their
life experience coming from cuba or
their family coming from cuba
one of our speakers had just come not
that long ago from venezuela
and i think that's a good example where
particularly with younger students
and their families again not conceiving
the logic but telling it from the heart
when you talk about
one of our speakers told me you know his
his parents came to america through
uh the freedom tower there in miami just
blocks from where we were at
uh and part of the reason why that came
was one of his uncles
was a political prisoner under castro's
regime for nine years the other for 18.
that's what socialism is about it
promises power to the people
but it really means poverty to the
masses and power in the hands of the
elite
we need to contrast those stories
whether it's venezuela
whether it's cuba whether it's the old
communist black countries or even
what we're seeing in hong kong and china
particularly china these days so that
was one part of it
uh the other part is is we've got this
incredible tip line
that's been capturing all these stories
from across america many are about
really abusive and out of control
professors sometimes about free speech
violations
but one of them goes to the heart of
what you're saying particularly about
younger ages
and that was from our students at iowa
state wasn't even about the campus it
was about the local school district in
ames iowa
not san francisco not new york city
ames iowa where the district teamed up
with blm
to have a blm week of action first week
of february for black history month
no problem with black history this had
nothing to do with it it was all
about indoctrination and they went from
kindergarten
to 12th grade and with kindergartners
they literally gave them coloring pages
of transgender people and told them that
they could pick their sex
and went on through the curriculum
throughout the grades to tell them
things like
fathers really didn't need to be a part
of the family anymore this
is what the left is doing yeah they're
trying to normalize it they're trying to
rationalize it
we need to push back we need to do it
sooner and not hide out there and think
somehow like you said we can wait till
debate class
uh in high school or even in college
that's too late for a lot of these folks
we got to start sooner that's why the
long game's so important well now as we
enter the
375th day of 15 days to slow the spread
we're hearing a lot of talk about the
new normal and i think it's just what
you say they're normalizing these things
well
when you do something long enough it
just becomes normal and so you know
you've seen this process build and build
to the point that now you have
transgender
indoctrination in kindergartens and blm
training
and it it reminds me of of
i think that what's so important about
yaf is that
you've got to state true things
you've got to state substantive things
we we defend free speech we defend
the free marketplace of ideas we defend
all these things in the abstract
but we also have something to say we're
also conveying a particular vision
of the country and i just think for for
far too long
conservatives seem to have been a little
afraid of doing that well claim the high
ground
we've got the facts on our side we've
got the substance on our side and i
would say
we have fairness we've just been afraid
to talk about one thing i talked about
my book
unintimidated uh was at the left people
like barack obama were so
good at grabbing the fairness issue yeah
when i talk about you know why is it
that one of the best teachers in the
state was one of the first to be laid
off
years before i was governor when they
did cut aid to schools and gave them no
tools
that's because the old union contract
said the last in is the first out
the first fire or the last hired i
should say is the first fire
well most people would say that's just
not fair yeah but we didn't tell those
stories so we have to tell those stories
again it's why we picked miami and why i
keep encouraging students
go find people who started their own
business from scratch go find people
whose family came
here from somewhere else legally and
immigrated to this country people forget
we're
we by far we have over a million people
every year who
legally immigrate to the united states
of america and there's no other country
even close to us when it comes to
foreign-born citizens
germany is the next closest country and
we're four times more
citizens that were foreign-born than
even germany is why
because people who come from other
places love america they want to be here
and
we need to tell those stories because
it's a great way to counter the crap
that we're hearing from the left from
from all these snowflakes out there who
somehow believed this nonsense
that we were you know that they were
born and raised in a country that was so
god-awful that they needed
exactly when the fact of the matter is
this is one of the greatest countries in
the history
not one of it is the greatest country in
the history of the world and it offers
unbelievable unbelievable opportunities
for people
and we should be out telling our
students how they can take advantage in
a good sense of those opportunities
instead of trying to sell this bill of
goods about how awful it is right the
social currency of grievance
people tend not to flee toward
oppression that's
fairly unusual think about it when i was
a kid so cuba i mentioned before
i can still remember those images of
people passing over
shark-infested waters right literally
with with rafts that were barely
floating above the water
piles of people on top why because they
knew of the freedom and opportunity
available uniquely
in the united states of america they
weren't going the other way they
weren't trying to find their way into
cuba and i think that's a telltale but
we have to be
we have to be strong enough to stand up
and say yeah we're not only going to
give the substance and the facts we're
going to tell it with the emotion that
ties into that and we're going to claim
the high ground when it comes to
fairness now
speaking of oppressors i do have to get
back to something that you just said
which reminded me i think you could give
some advice to
conservatives now about one issue in
particular
the teacher unions the teacher unions
nobody has stood up to teacher unions
like you stood up to them they are
keeping our schools closed for no reason
other than their own
laziness their own desire to make money
for doing nothing
their own desire not to listen to their
own members teachers who want to
actually get back and teach the students
and it seems like there is not a thing
that we can do about it
well we can we can hold our elected
officials accountable because that's
really what it's about it's not about
the teachers like you say
two of my wife's best friends are
teachers they have had it with zoom
yeah they want to see one in particular
teaches kindergarten she's pulling her
hair out trying to connect with kids
you know over zoom as opposed to being
in person the front line teachers the
people that
love their kids that want to make sure
they get the best education possible
they
want to be in the classroom they're the
same people that don't want to be a part
of an oppressive union to begin with
but but it's got to be a clear message
has to be delivered all the way up to
the
to joe biden that that the teachers
union bosses don't run america
the american people do and the unions
need to know that you're not an
essential worker
if you can't show up when it's essential
yeah i've got
my brother and my sister-in-law for
example my brother
is a manager at one of the convenience
store chains in wisconsin
uh my sister-in-law has been selling
appliances uh
since uh the first the 15 days after
that passed
she was back at the store they are both
front line workers who've been working
for the past year
and they just drives them crazy and
every other parent like them
that their kids can't go back to school
full-time now they've eased
into it unlike some places you know
across the country in new york and
elsewhere they haven't even been back at
all in a year yeah
this is unconscionable but the few times
i've ever agreed with the mayor of
chicago has been the last few months
when she stood up and said
particularly pointed out that young men
and women that look like her
that live in some of the most
impoverished neighborhoods in chicago
and for that matter elsewhere across the
country
are being the most hurt the most damaged
by not being able to physically be in
the classroom
this should be not just an economic and
practical issue this should be a
moral issue and it's about time people
across america stood up and held elected
officials accountable
for why they're not letting our kids go
back to school you know when we find
ourselves agreeing with chicago's lori
lightfoot something has gone seriously
wrong
in politics and you bring up another
issue i think that is kind of at the
heart of this long game
the vision for the future of
conservatism which is i hear from my
liberal friends they say michael look at
the lockdown it doesn't matter
you can just zoom to work you can you
stay at home you you know you zoom into
your consulting
job you look you're probably gonna end
up making more money frankly
and i think do you realize how out of
touch you are
with totally the majority of americans
and this is something that has changed
in my lifetime when i was a kid i say
this
totally i am a republican since the time
i registered
but the republican party was the party
of rich people and that's just the way
it was
and the democratic party was the party
of the working class and that just
is only the case how did it flip how do
we
how do we maintain that into the future
well you know a couple weeks ago
we were kidding before we went on set
here that there was you know think about
the royal family but everybody thinks
the big interview on cbs that night
uh was you know with with megan and
harry
i think it was a half an hour before 60
minutes had an interview with a series
of people
who some of whom are now homeless who
have been the forgotten men and women of
the pandemic
now they didn't connect the dots they
showed you the tragic side of it which
was tragic a woman
pregnant woman living in a tent in the
middle of columbus ohio
some other stories like that along the
way just i didn't watch the royal stuff
but the other stuff was
was really disappointing for anyone
thinking about people living in america
but what they didn't connect the dots on
is people like that woman that was
interviewed
were living in a tent after having built
up credit
opportunity before all the pandemic
because too many of our politicians
across this country have shut this
country down
and and that's where i i hope not only
from
yf standpoint but just in general when
people look at the difference between
the left and the right when they look at
states like florida
and texas versus new york and california
when they look at cities that are open
versus those that are not
i think it's very clear if you're a blue
collar worker if you're a family like my
brothers
you have no choice you have to show up
and this is what's interesting for all
the talk about race
and sex and and equality uh versus
equity i mean it's just
it's really interesting that the bottom
line if you listen to the american
people is
the people that have to show up every
single day or they don't get a paycheck
have had it with the people the
politicians who want to shut things down
right well you know
the folks who who zoom to work every day
god bless them there's a lot of good
people there too
but they're somewhat oblivious to the
challenges out there because
their kids can be in the other room on
one of their other laptops
you know my brother thankfully his
youngest is just 13 but if she was five
six years younger
what would they do right what would they
do and that's the america
not just politically speaking but i
think that goes back to part of
our goal with the long game yeah is to
reach out and get to get to those
families get to those students sooner
because it is disproportionately women
in the workforce
and people of color in the workforce who
have been the most hurt by the shutdowns
i think there's tremendous opportunities
for us to grow
in those families with those their sons
and daughters to say
we're the ones who believe in you
they're the ones who believe in the
government
right when you can't even yell when the
bureaucrats
in california claim that disneyland can
be open but you can't scream on a ride
that shows the sheer stupidity of the
government mentality just going down
just
sort of totally straight face hands in
the air
you you've just reminded me this
actually hadn't really occurred to me
until you said it
all this talk of racial justice and
equity
and sexual whatever
does seem to be a little bit of a cover
for a liberal elite establishment saying
keep giving your money to billionaires
in silicon valley who hate your values
keep no keep ordering from that one
company that hates your value and you
think
it seems like a bunch of bs is a cover
for a very corrupt establishment
well really and it goes back to this
marxist view of the world we've had a
number of our speakers some really
engaging folks who've spoke to our
our students through if programs uh and
many more that will come we'll talk
about things like critical race theory
and that and you
you can go all the way back to saying
many generations ago
marxist tried to impose their will here
in the united states and it didn't work
why
because we're not a class-based society
in america you can
grow up the poorest of the poor and you
can be president you can be ceo you can
be whatever your heart desires to be
because the opportunities are boundless
to the american people it's up to hard
work and determination and
hopefully access to a decent education
some skills
so what did they do well i think they're
cycling back
trying to create another set of class
battles to impose
a different form of marxism in this case
it's not economically based
it's based on race and gender and sexual
preference and things of that nature
the culture instead i mean right in
driving the culture
the easiest answer to all these
different challenges we've faced
particularly over the last year
is respect if we teach people
particularly if we go back to what
the bible teaches us and our
judeo-christian values in this country
about teaching people the the if you
you know you want to be treated the way
that someone or you want to treat
someone else the way you would like to
be treated and vice versa
if we live by those principles we
respect our fellow citizens we
we say we love america and we want our
children and our family to do well but
we also want you and your family to do
well
things would get much better instead
we've got these leftists and i would say
not just
not liberals but radicals who somehow
think they should determine what we
think and how we think
and they put their faith in the
government because they want the power
in the hands of the few
we want it in the masses you know you
know governor you know that i'm very
jazzed on this topic
having just written a book on this topic
but i guess this is what's gotten me so
excited about the long game is
as you say you have these marxists at
the end of the 19th and early 20th
century
and the culture the revolution rather
doesn't happen and
this is because as antonio gramsci says
the italian
communist theorist he says that the
conservatives have cultural hegemony
and the the left doesn't have it and
then this develops into critical theory
there are groups like the frankfurt
school all these
you know various sorts of intellectuals
who i think we should take seriously you
know
if you're going to if you're going to
fight them but then that gets
reformulated in the 60s
by the student radical rudy deutsche who
is reading ramsey
gramsci rather and he says we need a
long march
through the institutions and we're now
seeing the fruits of that ju
i mean just as you're describing these
radicals who have gained position
in all of these institutions and so one
day we look up and we say oh my gosh
they've got all these positions of power
and the minute truly the minute i saw
the
the cover here the name of the the long
game i said oh
finally a conservative is wising up to
what's been going on
and the beauty of this is we're not
imposing some foreign concept
yeah our long game is to bring back the
very founding principles right
to him to put in place what our country
was based on and what has allowed our
people
the people from so many generations
again those who were born here and those
that came here from elsewhere around the
world
to thrive those founding principles have
succeeded generation after generation
sadly we'd let them slip away
in in part because we took it for
granted
that it would just be that way yeah and
instead as you've aptly just
pointed out the leftist had a long-term
plan as well they they didn't this
didn't
happen overnight right this was a
long-term plan and undoing it
is going to take more than a new cycle
it's probably going to take even more
than a presidential cycle it really is
going to take
the long game and we're not going to do
it alone young america's foundation
we're excited we've got big plans we
hope people will go and
check it out and you know if they've got
sons or daughters nieces or nephews
grandsons granddaughters
if you're a student listening come and
join us right here we'd love to have you
be a part of our programs or support us
as part of our efforts
but we're going to have to partner with
others this is something the left is
really good at doing it
they get together lockstep we're not
talking about being lockstep but we're
saying join us
together not just as one organization
but as a movement that believes not just
conservative versus liberal
that believes in the founding principles
that made this country great and will
make it even greater going forward
join us in that effort you know i think
this this is the key because
the late conservative philosopher roger
scrutin he had this observation which is
that
it's very easy to destroy it's very
difficult to build
and going back we just mentioned
critical theory
critical theory is a very complicated
topic but it basically boils down to the
theory
to criticize it goes back to what mark
said uh in a
letter to arnold rougea i think where he
said
that he we must embark on the ruthless
criticism of
all that exists and you've seen this for
decades as criticism to tear down
america to tear down what the country
stands for to tear down our institutions
and we don't want to do that we want to
we want to build it back
up we want to recover something that's
been lost conserve what is here
and we can't do that alone and so i just
love that yaf has this big bold vision
and an organization in place
that that has a pretty good track record
on accomplishing these things
yeah that's a nice thing this is goes
all the way back six decades
it's got nationwide words but again we
can't do it alone and we
what we do we do well and that's a
testament to ron robinson the board
supporters great staff and most
specifically some wonderful students
you think of people like katie pavlich
who came to the reagan ranch
not knowing at all what she was going to
do and was totally transformed by our
speakers at that session
that's why we want to add a million more
students to our programs along the way
when you think of our conferences that
you've been keynoted at and
done your podcast and other events i
think someone like peter schweitzer
you know the obviously best-selling
author who does a fab
i think better research than anyone in
the at least on the conservative side
of looking into the facts and things
peter came to one of our national
conservative student conferences
and again transform where he's at so we
want to set a record number of
conferences going forward
and provide even more access to student
speakers and online
and youtube which you're a big part of
we'd love to have
5 million subscribers to our youtube
page and a billion with a b
a billion views when it's going forward
out there we want to be on every campus
and we want to go when you talk about
the working class not just on
undergraduate
i'd like to get into two-year associate
degree programs because those are really
practical students who want to get right
into the workforce
all those things we can do but it's
going to take partnerships and it's
going to take working together and we
it's not just that we can do it we have
to
right there's just too much at stake and
if we're going to beat the left
we've got to be engaged in every one of
these areas and some
to make the difference over the next few
years to save the heart and soul of our
republic
i'm excited in the short run i'm even
more excited for the
long game you can go to yaf.org
long game it's going to be to be
terrific you can catch me speaking at
the university of hawaii
i just want to get this on the table now
the university of hawaii would be great
but but at places all around the country
governor thank you so much
you know bill buckley obviously did so
much great work and yaf was founded
ron robinson did so much great work and
i know that uh
just like america's best days are to
come i have great hope and confidence
that that
the conservative movement's best days
are to come and specifically with the
leadership of you and yath
amen let's do it all right thank you for
coming on thank you